ist ein preisstock den Deutschland
gerade erlebt die Sorge von Millionen
Menschen das unser Alltag einfach nicht
mehr bezahlbar ist und doch gibt es
immer mehr Politiker und jetzt auch
Journalisten die sich darüber freuen die
sagen genau richtig wenn ihr es euch
nicht mehr leisten könnt dann verbraucht
halt einfach weniger so zum Beispiel
langsam Abend im Kommentar bei den ARD
Tagesthemen
er ist da der Preisschock gut so denn
nur wenn Öl und Gas spürbar teurer
werden kriegen wir die Erderwärmung in
den Griff mehr Windräder und
Solarenergie so lange können wir nicht
warten und sollten froh sein dass wir
gezwungen werden Konsum und Produktion
zu ändern achtsames heizen weniger
Energiefresser im Haushalt keine
Kurzstreckenflüge aber auch zum Beispiel
Stahl moderner herstellen oder Aluminium
und wollten wir das nicht sowieso nur
das jetzt die Märkte das Tempo diktieren
und nicht mehr unsere viel zu zaghafte
Politik
müssen wir uns noch mal ganz kurz
anhören
müssen wir uns hier glaube ich nochmal
fragen
er ist da der Preisschock gut so denn
nur wenn Öl und Gas spürbar teurer
werden kriegen wir die Erderwärmung in
den Griff mehr Windräder und
Solarenergie so lange können wir nicht
warten und sollten froh sein dass wir
gezwungen werden Konsum und Produktion
zu ändern achtsames heizen weniger
Energie Fresser im Haushalt keine er ist
da der Preisschock gut so
Chef das bildparlamentsbüros also erst
da der Preisschock und gut so
ja ich freue mich das ist
wir sollten dankbar sein dass wir
gezwungen werden das ist eigentlich eine
etwas seltene Haltung im politischen
Betrieb es klingt so ein bisschen wie
politische Sadomaso
zwingen mich dass ich besser werde in
einem Ernst der Preisschock ist
natürlich da das hat verschiedene Gründe
einmal Lieferengpässe bei Chips dann das
opec-kartell was weiterhin die Preise
für Öl und dementsprechend Energie hoch
hält und wir können von der Zentralbank
her nicht gegensteuern nur sich dafür zu
bedanken dass jetzt alles teuer wird das
ist schon sehr sehr zunehmen und
abgehoben gerade für diejenigen die froh
sind wenn sie mit einer schwarzen Null
Monatsende auf dem Girokonto rausgehen
das ist mir darüber sprechen wie eng es
für viele wird und wen das vor allem
alles betrifft also ganz konkret Ralf
was wird teurer und wen bei wem tut das
denn besonders
Energie ist vor allem betroffen also
Benzin haben wir gerade große
Höchststände für alle Pendler ist das
natürlich eine schwierige Geschichte
erfahrungsgemäß wird die
Pendlerpauschale dann irgendwann
angehoben aber sehr viel später auch
erst ab 22 Kilometer ist kann einfach
nicht jeder Ausweichen auf öffentliche
dann haben wir eine ganze Reihe von
consumer Produkten wie das in der warmen
Sprache so schön heißt also
Unterhaltungselektronik küchenelektronik
und ähnliches das ist jetzt nicht
zwingend dass man sich permanent neue
Sachen kaufen muss aber hin und wieder
muss es manchmal sein und wenn eine
Waschmaschine kaputt ist oder ein
Kühlschrank muss man es halt auch
ersetzen und das andere sind halt eben
auch Lebensmittel weil auch dort die
Ressourcen knapp werden und die Preise
steigen und wir haben im Augenblick
einen inflationsfenster von etwa vier
Prozent früher hatten hat die
Europäische Zentralbank zwei Prozent als
Ziel angepeilt und so schnell mit
Tariferhöhungen nachführen kann auch
nicht ja und Entlastung auch erstmal
nicht in Aussicht schon gar nicht eine
Regierung in Aussicht die sich um diese
Probleme aktuell kümmern das ganze
Inflation Richtung fünf Prozent und vor
allen Dingen merken was ja beim
Spritpreis so krass im Moment
mittlerweile an einigen Tankstellen der
Liter Benzin schon über
später und gerade haben wir es im
Tagesthemen Kommentar schon gesehen es
gibt immer mehr die sagen ist doch gut
so ist doch genau das was wir wollten
und auch die SPD-Politikerin früher
Justizministerin Katharina barley heute
in Europa unterwegs hat diesen Satz bei
den Kollegen von Hart aber Fair bei
Frank Plasberg gesagt
die Kilowattstunde die am billigsten ist
es die die man nicht verbraucht also
wenn man zum Beispiel sich neue Fenster
hat einbauen lassen oder gedämmt hat
also jetzt nicht einfach wird alles
gefördert genau also weniger verbraucht
dann kommt man voll in den Genuss dann
kann man sogar sagen hey jede Stunde die
jetzt teurer ist habe ich mehr gespart
also das ist die Haltung von vielen
Politikern aktuell die sagen genau das
wollten wir doch und jetzt wenn es euer
Problem ist dass ihr es euch nicht
leisten könnt reicht dann verbraucht
doch einfach weniger absolut und wenn es
kein Brot gibt kann man Kuchen essen
also die Sozialdemokratie an der Seite
zu haben da hat man aber echt ein Fund
ist meinte da spricht wirklich eine
Blinde von der Farbe wenn man sich
Fenster neu einbauen lässt dann zahlt
man in 10.000er Eurobereich wenn das
Haus dann selbst gehört als Mieter kann
man es ja nicht und man hat bei aller
Förderung natürlich trotzdem immer noch
ein gewaltigen Brocken den man zahlen
muss die Idee dahinter man kauft sich
effizientere Geräte mit denen spart man
dann so viel dass man die
Preissteigerung wieder auffängt die
funktioniert ja nicht das hat schon die
mineralsteuer gezeigt das hat die
Ökosteuer gezeigt immer die Idee ich
kaufe mir einen Kühlschrank mit der
Klasse A plus plus der wurde dann so
viel sparen dass ich den Mehrpreis und
die steigenden Energiepreise wieder rein
kriegen der funktioniert in der Praxis
nicht weil die Ersparnis einfach viel zu
gering ist im Vergleich zu dem was die
Energiepreise klettern was könnte die
Politik denn ganz konkret tun um die zu
entlassen die es am dringendsten
brauchen also Rentnerinnen und Rentner
Händler Geringverdiener gibt es da
Vorschläge also man kann natürlich den
Mindestlohn erhöhen man kann auch
also nicht politisch erhöhen sondern man
der wird ohnehin angepasst bleibt
trotzdem auf dem untersten Level wenn
man kann die
Geringfügigkeitsgrenzen anheben man kann
Steuerfreibeträge setzen und bei den
Renten gibt es natürlich im kommenden
Jahr ohnehin auch einen automatischen
Ausgleich also das Absacken der Renten
ist nach unten hin gedeckelt und nach
oben können Rentner was drauf das sind
also die Gruppen die am wenigsten davon
betroffen sind auch in die Zeit bis
dahin natürlich noch länger als
schwieriger ist es bei normalen
Erwerbstätigen die müssten über
Tarifabschlüsse mehr Geld fordern das
ist so schnell nicht zu machen auch bei
länger laufenden Tarifabschlüssen ist
das schwierig und ansonsten hat die
Politik einfach das Problem dass wenn
sie Abgaben senkt um Preise zu drücken
dass dann meistens die Unternehmen ganz
schnell mit ihren Preisen hochgehen und
das Ausgleichen so dass man nicht
wirklich eine Ersparnis hat aber die
Politik scheint seltsam entspannt noch
zu sehr ein angesichts der Ängste
angesichts der Sorgen von Millionen
Deutschen dass der Alltag eben nicht
mehr bezahlbar ist der SPD-Chef Norbert
Walter Breuers hat aktuell das hier
gesagt zur
Inflationsangst in Deutschland erhält
diese Angst offenbar überhaupt nicht für
berechtigt er sagt aktuell dem
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland dass wir
Deutsche uns angesichts unserer
Geschichte besondere Sorgen um Inflation
machen das ist verständlich aktuell
begründet sind diese morgen nicht sagt
Norbert Walter Breuers also
wir liegen irgendwie falsch oder ein
Höchststand seit 1993 in der Inflation
aber für Bayern
gut das ist jetzt auch mal wieder
sozialdemokratische Empathie pur
erklärt das sozusagen zu einer
historischen Marotte mit Blick auf die
20er Jahre Oma und Opa hatten damals
noch ihre Sparstrümpfe und über Nacht
waren das war das nur noch Pfennige wert
aber ganz so einfach ist es natürlich
nicht das Bittere daran ist wenn man
sich jetzt die koalitionsverhandlung
anguckt da gibt es große Einigkeit in
der Freigabe von Cannabis das ist sehr
schön aber die wirklichen Altersprobleme
die wirklich Millionen betreffen die
sind da einfach nicht im Blick und
solche Äußerungen kommen natürlich bei
Frau barley genauso wie bei Herrn bojans
von Leuten die die Fahrbereitschaft des
Bundestages in Anspruch nehmen können
die ihre Pensionen nach langen
politischen Leben völlig korrekt legal
und zu Recht gesichert haben und da auch
dann Anpassungen bekommen wenn die
Preise steigen das ist aber gerade zu
zynisch wenn man das den kleinen Leuten
auf der Straße erzählt wir wollen
darüber gleich auch sprechen mit dem
noch Bundesverkehrsminister andreas
Scheuer der ja kurz vor der Wahl
angekündigt hat die spritpreisbremse zu
treten wenn der Spritpreis über die zwei
Liter rüber rutscht jetzt haben wir das
an einigen Tankstellen schon mal gucken
was er gleich hier sagen wird bin vorher
wollen wir noch einmal hören was sie auf
der Straße aktuell sagen zur eigenen
inflationsangs und zum offenbaren
Schulterzucken der Politik aktuell unser
Kollege Michael Engelberg hat sie
umgehört in Bochum
[Musik]
die verarschen uns erstens den kleinen
Mann
und sie sehen
zu dass ihr Portemonnaie voll wird die
Kosten explodieren und es wird einfach
nichts gemacht auf der anderen Seite es
wäre ein Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet
obwohl die erneuerbaren Energien halt
überhaupt nicht in dem gleichen Maße
ausgebaut werden und wir importieren
immer mehr Energie die wir dann teuer
bezahlen müssen und das merke ich am
Ende auch in meinem Portemonnaie ja was
ich im Moment abspielt am man weiß nicht
was oben und unten ist sagen wir mal so
das einzigste was passiert ist die
Kosten sind in den letzten Jahren um
200% gestiegen was will man da sparen da
muss man immer nur drauflegen jetzt habe
ich hier ein paar Blümchen da da bin ich
10 15 Euro los das ist Wahnsinn was da
im Moment
passieren ist das auch bei diesen
Produkten gestiegen ja was ich im
Korbach ja das also Äpfel Kosten ein
Apfel 50 Cent wenn man es umrechnet ist
das eine Markt und der anna ist ja auch
nicht doof
denken Sie also so geht es ihnen dort
den Menschen zum Beispiel in Bochum mit
diesem Preisschock alles wird teurer
alles ist bereits schon teurer und ist
droht uns auch noch ein Winter wo alles
noch teurer wird und die Politik schaut
derzeit einfach dabei zu sein
[Musik]